so a couple of interesting reddit
threads from the David Pakman show
subreddit that I spotted this morning of
course the david pakman show subreddit
the biggest david pakman show audience
discussion forum on the internet at
david pakman.com slash reddit currently
fifteen thousand six hundred plus of our
viewers regularly participating in
discussions and commentary there i saw a
post about a conversation that one of
our viewers had with a trump supporting
friend who says the amount of mental
gymnastics these people do is unreal
this guy is a navy veteran
and our viewer said to his Navy veteran
friend how do you feel about your boy
Trump pleading guilty to stealing money
meant for veterans to fund his campaign
and our viewers Navy veteran friends
said oh my it's all one pocket they
steal my social security money all the
time so I'm used to it lol yeah that
that is an example of it's moving the
goal posts and it is sort of both sides
ISM and in a different form which is oh
listen Trump acutely defrauding people
through a charity that's sort of like
the government takes Social Security
money or this or that or I'm paying into
a system that I might not get money back
out of which of course that does not
actually appear to be true they are
mental gymnastics but this is a great
example of how can you argue with that
right how can you argue with someone who
will always find a reason to say now
it's actually not what you think and
it's not Trump's fault and my support of
him is not inconsistent or hypocritical
in some way I say don't bother and we
saw earlier this week the video of CNN
interviewing six uneducated white women
so to speak as they are effectively in
terms of the demographic group and you
saw that you know that it doesn't matter
what facts you present some of them will
talk around that if that's what they
want to do and that's why we just need
to focus on get out the vote we need to
focus on just getting people who already
agree with us to go out and cast a
ballot because you're not going to
convince people like that or at least if
you do the amount of time it'll require
will not lead to an effective
for winning an election also from the
David Pakman show subreddit this is
really interesting I saw the title and
the title is I'm becoming radicalized by
the right and then the viewer goes on to
say now the title isn't what you think
at first the rights actions and own
radicalization has made me a liberal
more radicalized in my opinion of them
as they become more radicalized I have
doubled down almost like a
radicalization death spiral another way
to put it I've seen them more be more of
a threat and a menace than fellow
countrymen it's to the point where I see
them as inferior closer to evil and
primal than civilized humans everything
they stand for I see is a threat and I'm
not sure what the answer is
in what to do about it this is very
interesting because we often talk about
radicalization that takes place which
makes which can take somebody who is for
example on the left and pull them to the
extreme right and I've heard from your
viewers who tell me David I used to be a
moderator on the left and the internet
echo chambers and algorithms radicalized
me to the right this is something
different but it's arguably also
problematic which is someone on the Left
sees the right becoming more and more
extreme and it makes them double down on
their own beliefs such that they start
to see the other side as something less
than human
as this viewer is saying it's ugly but I
don't think this is as rare as maybe we
might think a really interesting
perspective and I encourage you to
participate in the discussion on our
subreddit I'm there on a regular basis
producer Pat is there producer max is
there I'm not sure Noah's spending too
much time on the subreddit but hey
that's okay he's got a busy he's got
other tasks that he's working on david
pakman.com slash reddit re d di t